we have a 10 minute Gameplay trailer for
for spoken
uh this is a game that you may have seen
me pretty
heavily criticized I've said I think a
lot of the aspects of the gameplay
actually look pretty cool but um as part
of q a last week I answered a question
where someone asked me about the trailer
that was posted on Twitter the really
short one that was more of a spot and I
thought it was really bad as did a lot
of other people
um but at the same time I was like okay
this could just be really bad marketing
the marketing team might have even
written this this dialogue might not be
in the game at all I also think it was
really weirdly edited the music's not
there the character is over enthusiastic
about things that look very basic
um it was a really weird trailer and so
as somebody who always wants things to
be good I don't want this to be bad I'm
not going to go in watching this 10
minutes hoping that this game is going
to be bad I hope I'm wrong I hope it's
fantastic I hope we're all wrong and
it's great when we get another great
game to play that would be way better
so that's how I'm feeling about watching
this today is like okay
I have a lot of questions and things
that I want to see or reaffirm after
that Twitter trailer
let's just get into it shall we let's
just watch the forespoken 10 minute
Gameplay trailer and
[Music]
um
see if they they can make a little bit
of a marketing comeback with this
potentially
[Music]
[Music]
Frey Holland Daydreamer
I'm kind of bummed that it's not just
New Yorker Gameplay trailer
when she was mysteriously transported to
the beautiful treacherous land of Athea
a common anime guy arrives with a
magical sentient bracelet inexplicably
wrapped around her arm oh hello yes
she can cast powerful spells and use
magic to swiftly Traverse that looks fun
it looks super fun last remnants of
atheist populous soon look to Frey as
their only hope for confronting the
tantas once benevolent matriarchs who
now rule as maddened and Evil
sorceresses
reluctant to health but desperate to
find a way back home Trey sets off on a
journey through this strange and
dangerous land
I don't know what it is okay this is
gonna give us more of the one it's gonna
say something about it just doesn't look
unique and I couldn't tell you like why
the only Safe Haven in Athea is to Paul
where refugees have gathered to escape
the mysterious corrupting force of the
break this it just looks so Bland this
inhabitants will have quests to give or
information compared to older similar
games like older assassins
and Frey may even find a small friend to
act as a guide that's cute at this point
in Frey's Journey she has returned to
sepal from the wild after finding a rare
piece of adbaha or in the right hands
this ore may prove to be most useful
right
you've seen this stuff before
I've made armor out of it
no less whoa you made that armor does
that mean you can do something cool with
this stuff oh no
but I'd need the right tools and where
can I find those and I love the vo I was
hoping that the marketing was just weird
I'll draw you a map and give you the key
you'll have to do the rest yourself
yeah it sucks you can bring them back as
someone who has done voice acting and is
not good
it's not easy to do
and so I always feel bad whenever I
dislike it like even worse than other
people because I'm not very good at it
and I know that I'm still learning
um
but it's so easy to criticize things
that we can't necessarily do
that that that Cadence of you've done
this before I can find it in the city is
just so not human ah it's really it's
jarring it's a bummer it's a bummer so
that part of the trailer that I was like
I don't know that she's a bad actor I
don't even know that it was bad Vo
it's probably exactly what she was
directed to do
still isn't necessarily true but it does
seem consistent that uh I guess I
personally
um don't love the performance which
again I say is someone who is bad at
voice acting also I'm gonna make myself
smaller give me a second
whip okay
and that's a big if I'll make you
something with that all of yours
[Music]
it's giving me Ubisoft vibes
[Music]
outside the safety of support the only
life Ray we'll encounter are corrupted
enemies looking to rip her limb from
limb you have got to give this game
credit and I'm I know that people want
to drag every part of it I think this
traversal looks awesome
I think if you're trying to tell
yourself that it doesn't either we just
politely disagree and that's okay or
you're trying to hate it I feel like
this looks like it's gonna be really fun
to Traverse that is a standout positive
to me
work of low-level enemies
and her magic enhanced parkour abilities
turn this inhospitable land into her
personal playground
I hope it gets faster though
measure chest stop the Landscapes and
contain items used for crafting or
trading with vendors back very Ubisoft
very Ubisoft with less in it leveling up
but it can also be found in glowing
pools around Athea collecting enough
Mana allows Frey to unlock new spells
[Music]
with the help of her golden companion
cuff Frey can scan belfries golden
companions before continuing her journey
the place on Joe heady's map isn't it
are you planning on retrieving her
smithing gear might as well while we're
here besides I want to know more about
Sila and jokini Noor
it's very stiff
also I just
I just feel like
the marketing for this game is just like
if you were just shown us a mission or a
boss fight
something about the marketing of this
game is wrong something about it is
wrong maybe it's that they don't know
what it is or who it's for
but like what you're choosing to show me
as though
you know it's super impressive was like
talking to an NPC and then walking
through a city that again looks a lot
like a less populated Assassin's Creed
the combat does look cool why did you
bury it
under
I don't know man it's just a strange one
this looks cool I would enjoy this this
combat I love this kind of combat
[Music]
this is a weird cut
maybe maybe this is in a house well
we have a few things to attend to First
yeah it looks that way let's break some
heads
even though yeah it looks that way let's
break some heads
and then just like
very epic music for what's probably a
pretty standard fight
it's just such such a disconnect
the combat looks cool
it looks like a more involved version of
some of my favorite MMO combat to be
honest
looks like this is the place well here
we go
damn this stuff is heavy the reassuring
heft of odwaha
[Music]
why would you keep in vo of someone
going so much to find this stuff is
heavy like I'm exploring what you should
put up for completing a quest is always
worthwhile
a variety of rewards which of us looks
sick or unlocked including experience
points I'm getting like dark side as
prototype Vibes like a mix between the
two a new gear this thing just dreams
prop why not try it on
William's what
ready
while Frey is mysteriously immune to the
corrupting influence of the break
nothing else in Athea can escape its
grasp
humans are turned into Savage zombies
and worse while animals are mutated into
dangerous beasts
interesting
I wonder if there's a melee have I
missed it is that Pilgrim's refuges are
hideaways located in every part of athia
and it's always a good idea to seek them
out
here Frey can craft healing drafts
upgrade gear and get some much needed
rest
I feel like this maybe like again it's
pretty basic stuff
maybe would have been better as a Dev
content ready for the next step of her
journey
and here you see corruption there was
some sort of European yeah but I think
the studio is there you see play and
while Frey may be resistant to them
undoubtedly be pushed to her limits
I don't think she said that there I
think that was put in there
combat continues to look cool
this does look cool
[Music]
I think the combat's gonna be super fun
Frey will encounter numerous points of
interest in her travels
many of these landmarks and locations
have been corrupted or overrun with
corrupted enemies but they're always
worth seeking out
well this doesn't look good yes
something seems to have drawn the break
here but I expect you can clear it away
with your panels give it a try yeah I'm
not like I don't think her her dialogue
is like maximum cringe worst thing on
the planet
but this is insane
and
well this doesn't look good
it's just not very compelling
that's enough exploring for now and not
even really stuff that actual humans say
that all and deliver the smithing tools
to Joe heady
all done okay so it is a single Quest
just caught up
also I like what the hell is this
what did you expect a full suit of armor
[Music]
it's cool I just
like you to lump it that's the last bit
of smithing I'll be doing for a while
phrase Journey will take her to the ends
of this beautiful cool land
and in her search for a way home she
discovers something worth fighting for
[Music]
it's like a lot of cool visuals with a
bunch of other stuff that's kind of
bland is sort of the problem
which which leaves you just feeling a
bit strange
um
January 24th 20 23. so there are things
that I like about this more than what
I've previously seen at the game but I
have to be looking for it I think this
is a bad presentation I think this is
another bad trailer
obviously very subjective I'm sure there
are loads of people who enjoyed this but
from my perspective it's another one
that's like
okay
yep cool what do you chose that line of
VO to sell your character like it's the
lines are just so like Marvel
um
it's a really weird one I feel like this
isn't common it's Square Enix marketing
I really don't know
I think the traversal looks cool I think
the combat looks cooler here than I had
seen previously or maybe it's that I'm
paying more attention
but I'm ultimately just like not very
excited to play it and I think that that
is because of the weird like
sort of samey bland stuff in between
which is such a bummer um again one all
games to be good I don't know
it's a weird one